now in the race for space travel a
manned rocket has taken a very special
tourist into orbit 90 year old actor
william shatner best known for playing
captain kirk in the cold science fiction
series star trek after blasting off the
crew travels for roughly 11 minutes and
experienced a few minutes of
weightlessness it was the second manned
rocket by blue origin one of the
companies in the race to commercialize
space travel
william shatner was one of four crew
members and is now the oldest person to
travel into orbit after he landed he was
greeted by blue origin founder jeff
bezos
mr shatner was visibly moved by the
experience
i'm so
filled with emotion about what just
happened i i just
it's extraordinary
i hope i never recover from it the
vulnerability
of everything it's so small
this air which is keeping us alive
is thinner than your skin
it's it's a it's a
it's a sliver it's
it's immeasurably small well keith
cowing is editor of the website space
spaceref.com welcome to dw um is sending
captain kirk into space anything more
than just a great marketing by jeff
bezos
it is great marketing and if you want to
get the perfect pitch man you want one
that's perfectly aligned with your
product and if you know of a better one
please let me know i think this was
flawless in terms of marketing
and what sort of demands is a 11 minute
flight into orbit likely to put on a 90
year old like william shatner
well i actually did some training for a
blue uh for a virgin galactic flight in
the centrifuge which is a little more
rigorous and i was in my late 50s and i
pulled six two point g's and i was you
know just fine afterwards so what this
shows is that virtually anybody who can
walk up and down the stairs has the
right stuff and can go into space
so long as they can afford to buy the
ticket or get a free one william yeah i
saw him interviewed and he was saying
that the toughest thing about the whole
thing was actually getting out of the
chair
yeah
well imagine that it's easier to go into
space than to you know get in and out of
a chair that should that should tell you
something
who benefits from this besides the the
money man does space tourism benefit
science or or is it just about the money
well you know it depends which subset of
this if it's just getting in for a quick
ride then you know maybe it has limited
benefit but then again you know you go
on vacation or holidays that has clear
benefit for people but the more
important thing is that these vehicles
that can go up and come back and be
reused have a potential to do more than
just going into space or going through
space shall we say spacex is building a
large starship which is much bigger
which will allow what's called a
suborbital hop in other words you get in
one of these rockets in london and
you're in sydney australia 50 minutes
later so the potential for these is not
what they do today but what they can
lead to in the next five to ten years
isn't that interesting and so
looking perhaps
10 years perhaps 50 years can we see can
you see
the idea of space being commercialized
can you see people i don't know take
paying to go to the moon for instance
and then actually staying up there
uh i i can imagine it of course i'm
predisposed to do that because i've been
imagining it since i was a little little
boy but uh yeah i think it's become real
in the sense that
if this follows the path of other things
like air travel it started as something
that only rich people could do and now
we complain about you know not having
enough leg room so you know if people if
enough people want to do something there
are people who will find a way to offer
it to people for cheap
okay carrying uh thank you so much
you've given me much to think about
there thank you
my pleasure